some races today we're gonna play some
survivors I think on base got everything
for this Midas games are pretty exciting
so let's take it nice and slow
very nice and slow how much more all
right so this is Daisy I can roll
anything you're doing these games
alright well now I'm being chased by a
crazy person stop I think I skipped
leave me alone please will and you were
hey blue hat ah ding okay now how how in
heaven's name
I am leaking blood I should swim like a
blood ah I hear some kids hi what are
you doing with that sledgehammer don't
hit me
it's my only hat it go outside I don't
with you I don't know who you are okay
fine I have a green hat I'm the most
trustworthy person ever do you have any
food please gonna have some on stuff in
today umm I don't know if you notice but
I'm leaking how what do you say we go
find a Tesco we're not smart enough I
got it no I got it
look what did you do mate [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] Mouse I
can't see what I'm gonna what what the
[ __ ] is happening I love games cuz they
are fun video games here
no games I just played a Zed and no one
tried to kill me
[ __ ] I think I'm BAE's got everything
for next game stomping land this game
was a best-seller for a long time when
it came out I can see why
smack that tree Hey look at Danis ooh
wow wow oh my god we're playing
that's so cute what are you doing Danny
soo ah the [ __ ] is wrong with you I bet
there's way cooler dinosaurs out there
than you [ __ ]
well if you like walking you'll love
these games sorry if you like pressing
down the W button you'll love these
games now that Dan is so maybe this one
is friendly will you be my friend I
think that is a yes
by the day
these I think I'm basedgod everything
far I start off by dying cool I'm
sleeping why am I so sexy
hey look hey you're next up is rust rust
actually looks nice I gotta say stupid
house another naked man hi naked man how
are you naked man wait we're naked let's
be naked together
my naked pink son of a [ __ ] you will be
mine
I have present for you naked man come
here fight me like a naked man okay
alright like I hit him Oh naked man
fight Oh
hit that [ __ ] oh it's triple naked man
fight this is my favorite ah ooh penis
hey let's like what's in the chest I'm
[ __ ] stuck oh boy I sure had fun
surviving with you bros today if you had
fun too
go ahead and leave it like it subscribe
come birthday and I will see you in the
next video as always thank you for
watching stay awesome
you